and what I've seen is Chase this week
went and attacked myON and I'll tell you
what myON used to trigger me early on he
really did um you know he would say
things that I thought he was harsh or
rude and I I really I wasn't the biggest
fan and the longer I listened to him the
more I realized he's actually one of the
few guys that tell the truth the other
guys are pandering the other guys are
telling you what you want to hear and I
realiz this because sometimes when I say
something that's uncomfortable like I
say that men and women in the church are
not of a higher moral quality than out
of the church I get so many people they
attack my faith they attack my family
they they just go after me and even
though that's true I know that's true
I've been alive for 27 years I've been
involved in many different types of
churches and I've interacted with church
people and non-church people I don't see
a difference and what I realized is myON
was saying things that hurt your
feelings a bit if you see my um I went
on his show like three years ago and I
argued I
said high value men don't cheat and I
thought he was just talking
but then I interviewed a thousand
people and I really looked at the world
and I tried to be as honest as I could
without my personal feelings getting
into it
and he was right men not dorks with
money that's different dorks with money
don't cheat but men that typically have
the ability to pick up
women tend to sleep with
multiple they might go a time period
without but usually it is hard for men
to Turn Down Easy sex it just is and if
you're a chick and you're married to a
guy
that is that guy which most of us won't
be I mean let's just be honest most
women will not get that guy but if you
do I think it's easier to just accept
that that might happen rather than go
looking for problems it might happen and
it's not the biggest deal men and women
view sex differently men can have sex
and not care about a woman women it is
not the same this is not to say it is
morally okay
but I mean this is the way of the world
and women it's so funny because these
Church women have such a high they're on
such a high horse they think they're
better than everybody and they'll go
around lecturing these men about
sleeping around when what were they
doing at 22 95% of women are not virgins
on their wedding nights so they too also
had sex with multiple men
so it's a bit hypocritical and that's
what I want to talk about right now the
hypocrisy in the church is crazy it is
crazy crazy crazy now I know everybody
is a hypocrite and I do I do I would
like to separate I know you can say that
a sin is wrong
and that's fine but what I saw with
Chase is he starts attacking myin and I
keep seeing all these people attack Myra
and attack the red pillars and call them
degenerates when them and their youth
did the same thing are you too then a
degenerate how are you any different and
what they'll say is I said sorry after I
am different because I said sorry there
was no sense of humility with them none
they are the red pillars are the evil
evil
degenerates and what annoys me about
this was a clip chase this guy that's
going around calling us the evil
degenerates um said that you know myin
is the problem right myin myON myON so
evil because
he slept with the multiple women now if
he wants to say it's immoral
fine but if you're if you're attacking
someone personally and then you're going
on a podcast
saying that you did the same thing two
months ago you know it's one thing it's
like okay if you were imagine if you
were a business coach and you said run
your business like I run my business and
then went bankrupt two months ago you
would kind of think huh and then you
would kind of look at their past and he
said he was celibate for three years so
before three years ago doing the same
thing you would look and you would say
huh so he's going bankrupt every three
years his way isn't working really well
and this is I want to have an honest
conversation with the church about what
I actually see in the church what I see
generally is a bunch of simp men with
overbearing controlling wives that you
used to be
hoes
now I do believe in Redemption so what I
am not saying is that God cannot forgive
you for sins what I'm not saying is that
women there's no hope for women that's
not what I'm saying
but it's kind of like if you guys are
selling religious marriage okay and
you're that's your cell you're saying
guys religious marriage is the
way well we want to look at your wives
and see no kids no Nudes on the internet
no crazy past and I'm sorry guys that is
not what we're seeing and Men naturally
just make a cost benefit analysis that
that's what they naturally do regardless
of what Pearl says regardless of what
anyone says they're going to look at and
see are you getting the results that I
would
want and unfortunately and I want to I
want to I want you to not just take my
word for it I actually want to show
you um I want to show you
a one of the biggest Chastity speakers
and I know them because they came to my
high school so these people had a
significant impact in the culture okay
they were huge in the Catholic spere and
guys I'm using my religion as an example
and there's way worse religions out
there um Catholics are generally I would
I would argue less corrupt than the rest
not much hear this this is humility
right not much but I would say we don't
have you know a freaking band in church
we're not you know it's it's a bit more
scriptural and even us this is what this
is what we
have
okay I'm going to show you simping
simping sing sing
also I'm going to want look for the cash
apps if if there are any just you
know I want to talk about dating and how
that's is this
2x oh no it's not okay evolved since you
started speaking 20 years ago because
the complaint I often hear you often
hear no doubt I'm sure is women saying
like I don't get asked out or men don't
you know they they don't want to date or
I see you know and I know so many
beautiful women in their 20s and their
30s who still aren't married
and it's it can be heartbreaking I don't
mean to blame this all on the on the
dudes but it's an epidemic because I I
think and when I talk to women are going
like I'll go to a daily mass at noon
downtown in some City while I'm speaking
and you see all these attractive young
single professional women there devout
and the guys aren't anywhere
around the women are amazing it's all
the men's fault see this keep you go to
Catholic Young Adult Community sometimes
and it's you know four to one you know
young single women and uh but why are
the men leaving the church why this is
what they're not talking about it's all
on the it's all on the men always on the
men why are they leaving and I think
what's going on is in China you know
they've had this one child policy for
decades and as a result if you can only
have one kid in China you want a male
passes on the family name the males are
esteemed so much more highly than the
women so the female babies are being
aborted at an exponential rate compared
to the male babies now that this been
going on for enough Generations you have
lot of single young Chinese males that
are looking for a mate and she's not
there because they were aborted by the
millions and they're looking around and
they're gone I think we're having the
opposite problem in America because of
pornography that men have been
emasculated to such an but why are they
watching
it what about these sexless marriages
what about women's high standards see
this is a guy talking that has very
little experience in the dating scene he
doesn't know what's going on okay exent
that the women are reaching a level of
marriage age and maturity and the guys
are 24 but they're 12 years old
emotionally they're still playing their
video games at home they're afraid to
ask a girl out without an app they don't
even know how to ask the girl out and so
the women are looking around like wait a
minute God I'm ready to raise a family
and start having kids and doing this but
where are the decent guys they're hooked
on porn and they're playing video games
and they're just not ready not even not
even a word about women being addicted
to social media
here's the funny thing women are pushing
off marriage women have more control
than ever but yet simp men in the church
continue to blame everything on the men
and this whole
conversation 80% of women partake in
some sort of hookup culture 10 maybe 20%
of men do and yet what have been
tradcons been bitching about all week
the men the men the men the men the men
you guys you it drives me crazy okay it
drives me crazy wait did it was the
sound okay was the sound okay one in the
chat if the sound's
okay drives me nuts okay Philip thank
you very much for the venmo thank you
appreciate you uh let me check cash app
really quick okay we're all right oh oh
and fasil ly thank you very much
so okay there there's one example and
I'm not done this I'm going to go in
because I grew up around this stuff I
grew up around this stuff so I you guys
aren't fooling me these people aren't
fooling me so why are men leaving the
church all right so nearly 96% there's a
a study asking why young adults are
leaving the church 96% cited Life
Changes including moving to college and
working responsibilities that prevented
them from attending so okay that's one
the second one guess what it was guys
guess what it
was 73% said church or Pastor related
reasons LED them to
leave so like Chase is doing the
Hypocrites of those 32% said church
members seem judgmental or
hypocritical 29% said they did not feel
connected to others and I pulled the men
on Twitter I asked them for men that
used to be religious why did you leave
that was one of the biggest
things but you're right guys Pearl's
just making this up I'm just the
evildoer now again I want to think about
this from the men's point of view does
this sound like a w does this sound like
women like who who are are they blaming
this
on and let me know in the chat if the
sounds off or
[Music]
anything and mind you these are the
Catholics the Catholics don't have gay
flags yet they don't have any of that
stuff these are the Catholics everyone
okay now I'm coming from a completely
different angle than Jason here when I
was about a sophomore in high school I
had my first serious relationship and
after a while of dating we thought we
were in love and everything was great
and slowly we started to get very
physical and slowly the pressure started
to set into the relationship and it came
to a point where he said well girl if
you really love me you truly love me
you'd prove it to me you'd show me just
how much you love me so I needed advice
so I went to my girlfriend's and I said
Well he kind of wants to do this with me
and he wants to do that and they said
well if you aren't doing this with him
all right do you
see already whose fault is it I didn't
want to have sex I wasn't the one
pushing it oh it was him he said he said
if I really loved him this is what I had
to do
like you
the bullsh I just want I just want us to
call it what it is guys that's that's
what I get so irritated about I don't
want to play pretend I just want to call
this stuff what it is you wanted to have
sex it wasn't his fault you wanted to
okay what's wrong with you everybody's
doing it you love him right and I
thought well yeah I love him so at the
age of 15 I lost my virginity thinking
it was going to cause this huge great
emotional bond between us and we'd be on
cloud n and so in love and in all
actuality eventually any love we had in
that relationship was just thrown out
the window because if I couldn't respect
my own body how's he supposed to respect
it and after a while of dating it seemed
like he don't want to spend time with me
anymore he was basically spending the
time with my body and when a person is
being used
okay men want sex silent
sandwiches I
no she doesn't she doesn't talk about I
don't
know the reasons men don't want to get
married they used to get married in
three months a hundred years ago it's
all he's using my body okay they know it
they know it in the depths of their
heart they may deny it they may ignore
it and I Know It And okay see women I'm
G to show you and after a while we are
constantly fighting he was cheating on
me and we went our separate ways now I
will never forget the day day when he
walked away from me for the very last
time and as he walked away from me all I
could think about was that guy's taking
something with him that never belonged
to him in the first place but I can't
get it back right what's the point it's
already gone so there I was in the
cafeteria talking with my girlfriend and
I came to this conclusion okay well if a
guy can date me for about 6 months
without sleeping with me then he must
love me
then I'll sleep with him notice how
she's never talked about what she has to
do for
him he's using
me but what I mean we want their
attention so what you're taking
attention from them are they being you
just and I think now six months six
months is the price that I put on my
body if he gives me just a little bit of
that time and a little bit of that
attention that's the definition of love
and I carry this mentality all through
high school he was the first guy but he
wasn't the last and I went down this
vicious cycle and I'm not standing up
here pointing my finger you guys saying
you guys you're the problem it's all
your fault no I happen to believe you
guys will be as much of a gentleman as
we ladies require now I wasn't acting
like a lady back then nor dressing like
a lady back then therefore they didn't
feel the need to rise up and act like a
gentleman around me and what seems to
happen sometimes is that girls will give
guys sex for the sake of getting the
love from them and guys will give girls
the love for the sake of getting the sex
from the girls and it can go both ways
now with this lifestyle I got into the
partying I got into the drinking I got
into the clubbing you name I'm just
saying if you're G to parade your
relationship around as the one to be
like again men are going to look at the
product they're going to say is this is
this product
good
are most men going to be super excited
to have a wife that's talking about her
ex-boyfriend 15 years
later and talking about her ho escapades
now I know maybe I'm not saying it like
that maybe that we don't like how that
sounds but men are going to look at that
and say huh so if I if I do this church
stuff this is what I
get
okay I was into it and Grant at the time
yeah I thought it was a lot of fun it
was very attractive and I know what
that's like but I also know what it's
like to wake up the next day when that
party's over when your friends are gone
and when you're there by yourself and I
remember waking up thinking I can't
believe I did that last night I hope I
don't have to see his face in the
hallway at school on Monday what if he
tells everybody what we did all of these
things constantly going through my head
but the night before my friends would
always say oh it's all fun and games
don't worry about it it's not a big
deal it was her friends do you see this
like I just
can't no okay when you up you did
it because you wanted to like ladies
ladies ladies I just I wanna I want to
repeat this okay I did it because I
wanted to I did that and I M up no it's
not your friend's fault no it's not your
boyfriend's fault maybe it was just you
messed up and this stuff is so rampant
in the church it is always it's always
and and all the tradcon guys that say
they're different are doing the exact
same thing